[Music]
every new year ushers in countless new
nanny state bans in Los Angeles
supermarket chains can no longer give
out free plastic grocery bags from now
on either bring your own or shell out
ten cents per sack so what will it be
paper or plastic Illinois a state so
well-run that it faces billions of
dollars in unfunded pension obligations
now bans anyone under the age of
eighteen from going to a tanning salon
residents also face a fifty dollar fine
for flicking a cigarette butt in the
street or on the sidewalk Delaware has
banned the sale possession or eating of
shark fins and New York City has banned
horse-drawn carriage rides Major League
Baseball has even banned home plate
collisions the list is long and Graham
and seemingly endless but the worst
nanny state ban going into effect in
2014 is almost surely the federal
prohibition on the production of new
incandescent light bulbs this band was
years in the making the 2007 energy bill
enthusiastically signed by then
President George W Bush effectively
killed incandescent light bulbs by
energy efficiency mandates 175 watt
bulbs were phased out in previous years
and now cheap 60 and 40 watt light bulbs
once the very symbol of a good idea are
verboten in the land of the free
before the incandescent bulbs go dark
for good it's worth shining a light on
the band's cause it was pushed by light
bulb makers eager to upsell customers on
longer lasting and much more expensive
halogen compact fluorescent and LED
lighting when customers balked at paying
more for home lighting General Electric
Sylvania and Phillips did what corporate
BMS do all the time they turn to the
government for regulations that rigged
the market in their favor so when you
throw out that last 40 cent 40 watt
light bulb
member that you're not just tossing out
a piece of history you're also throwing
out a piece of the free market but not
all never forget the importance of life
the reason TV I'm Nick Gillespie